la première fois j'ai entendu parler de
la culture tout seul je pense que je
veux vraiment identifié comme en réalité
la tante d'anne et adjiwanou oeuvres au
centre des femmes de l'uqam les ravages
de la violence sexuelle
elle connaît voilà pourquoi elle n'a pas
hésité à assurer l'organisation d'une
nouvelle marche défense c'est de dire
bon c'est magnifique que les gens se
soient mobilisés
il ya une prise de conscience au moins
c'est ça m'arrivait et ont déclaré ce
bleu et maintenant qu'est ce qui se
passe je peur qu'il n'aura pas une
grande mobilisation
mais je comprends la frustration parce
que en plus ton appart femme noire s'est
elle offert quelques invités black lac
majeur comment donner une suite à la
vague moi aussi parlez-en au centre
d'être contre les victimes de violences
si moi aussi à inspirer des milliers de
femmes brésil silence
il a aussi laissé pour compte des
milliers d'autres victimes
il est très très blanc très bourgeois et
ça c'est une partie du problème
pourquoi en effet on entend parler de la
violence sexuelle mais de la perspective
de la femme blanche temps quand on
entend beaucoup parler du sexy entend
beaucoup parler du patriarcat
mais on n'entend pas parler d'autres
types de discriminations qui s'ajoute
îles qui font en sorte que certaines
populations sont davantage on oublie
trop souvent que me to any de
l'initiative d'une femme noire pour
venir en aide au jeune fille noire du
sud des états unis
pause qui a été grossièrement négligé
dans le débat public entourant la vague
des dénonciations ultra médiatisé
concède la présidente de la fédération
des femmes du québec nous présentement
en 2018 je crois que ça doit être
deuxième étape dans le mouvement mais
tout c'est à dire d'écouter les
expériences qui n'ont pas été entendus
et s'assurer qu'on les inclus dans le
mouvement et qu'on base nos actions sur
les gens qui sont les plus marginalisées
et qu'on a historiquement laissé
derrière manque d'inclusivité risques de
dérives
gabriel bouchard entend les critiques
elle a constaté le ressac qui se dessine
face à moi aussi ça m'effraie pas c'est
vrai que je vois pas non plus
nécessairement de dérive je vois
beaucoup plus un appel à faire mieux
et cet appel est inconfortable donc je
nous invite collectivement à ça c'est
s'asseoir dans cet inconfort nord et
prendre le temps de les observer dans ce
riche vrai qu'on fasse un peu c'est
peut-être réviser le dico rassemblés
autour d'un enjeu qui forcent
d'importantes remises en question les
organisatrices de la marche opte pour un
message pièce 1 on agit
5 passes donc c'est vraiment ça de faire
un peu un appel à la population pour un
appel à l'action
donc on se mobilise entre nous puis là
on agit ça passe plus on parle puis on
prend des actions concrètes
il faut vraiment profiter du moment pour
faire la sensibilisation et c'est pas
pour que les hommes à y percer pour
qu'ils s'informent sait pour qui ils
soient confrontés à que c'est une
problème qui est sociétale car pour
espérer changer les mentalités
le mouvement moi aussi devra dépasser
les cercles des femmes
yp allemand blanche interpeller
l'ensemble de la population même surtout
les hommes ici emmanuelle latraverse
radio-canada rien
[Musique]